il a mis le mais porte encore sur son
corps les marques d'une agression
sexuelle
son sentiment d'injustice lui est gravé
dans son esprit c'est vraiment le
parcours du combattant
la survivante n'était pas préparé à ce
qu'il attendait bien que prépare au fait
pendant l'enregistrement de ta plainte
d'être obligé de m'y mets ton violent
puis moi c'est quelque chose qui m'avait
été demandé de l'apport de l'anc est
triste et c'était tellement difficile
que j'en ai perdu mes moyens qui c'est
de voir aussi la lenteur et la lourdeur
du processus it et de voir que tu payes
deux ans et demi en suspens sans savoir
quel va être l'aboutissement de ce vous
avez vraiment le choix vous de consulter
de façon constante et lé 4 août un
avocat juripop offre désormais des
conseils juridiques gratuits pour les
victimes
87 avocat travers le québec sont à
l'écouté on va les aider à comprendre
c'est ce qu'ils ont vécu c'est illégal
ou si ça constitue un crime puis le cas
échéant on va les aider à comprendre
leur recours à les comparer entre eux
aussi puis si elle décide d'entreprendre
des recours on va les assister là dedans
ils se répondent au mouvement
international de dénonciation des
inconduites sexuelles moi aussi qui
s'attaquent entre autres aux abus de
pouvoir on est vraiment inquiet des des
risques de harcèlement au travail qui
vont suivre le déconfinement pourquoi
parce que ça fait des mois que la santé
mentale la santé financière des gens et
fragiliser les victimes de violences
conjugales peuvent aussi recevoir de
l'aide
dans beaucoup de cas les femmes ont des
enfants devront aller au tribunal de la
famille pour régler les questions de
garde accès dans certains cas la
protection de la jeunesse est aussi
impliquée donc il ya plusieurs systèmes
qui sont complexes qui n'ont pas les
mêmes règles
la justice devient un peu plus
accessible ça permet de limiter au moins
la réutilisation secondaire qui se passe
quand on raconte cette histoire est que
finalement on n'est pas entendu qu'à nos
droits sont peu respectés une façon pour
que les survivantes reprennent le
contrôle ici genève garon radio canada
montréal